woher kommen die träume
träumte ich sei eine frau
ich hatte flügel
und spannend mich über die wolken
so ich weiß nicht welcher deren welt
empor
warum das schön gesänge agenten durch
verleihen
nichts als drei weißen wollten mich
hätte den äther
einen shopping
ich war das mädchen
mit einem weinen
langen gesunde an metallen
plötzlicher staaten am flügel
das schloss sich über mir wie eine
kristallkugel und nicht
und eine schwere kette legte sich mir um
den hals deren gewicht mit 4 1 ab und
zog
sein vater kind hat sollte ich von der
größe der männlichen und den
naturgegebenen und gesellschaftlich
akzeptierten schädlichkeit der
weiblichen rolle überzeugt werden ihr
könnt auf diesen tafeln gefressen sehen
wo man für uns anfertigen ließ hier der
raub der sabinerinnen auf dem hier per
fahrrad hier strafe der daneben und
jetzt kommt mein liebstes der verkauf
von sklaven im orient auf weiteren sind
verstoßene königinnen verraten und
vechte geliebte und hinduistische witten
zu sehen die auf den scheiterhaufen
ihren männern geopfert werden auf allen
ist die frau sklaven eroberung eigentum
die die versucht sich durch lug und trug
fahrrad feig und unnötige verbrechen
ihrer fesseln zu entledigen um sich
einer noch erbarmungsloser und einigung
auszusetzen
in diesem prozess für land und leuten
die strukturen aufgezwungen werden die
das internationale kapital für seine
herrschaft braucht es geht um die
ausrichtung aller werte auf seine
prinzipien die neben dem materiellen
elend von millionen
auch die armut in den köpfen und herzen
der menschen bedeutet
nur zu oft wurde mir erklärt was einmal
raus und wie die erbfolge eines
fürstentums mit allen dazugehörigen
titel privilegien und reichtümern auf
dem jeweils ältesten männlichen
sprösslingen übergeht wenn die
eigentlich berechtigte linie nur noch
als züchter mächtig
[Musik]
wenn man sich den kapitalistischen
werten unterordnet muss man ein leben in
vereinzelung akzeptieren menschen die
isoliert und ohne wirkliche
kommunikation sind sind weit davon
entfernt sich eine andere wirklichkeit
gemeinsam mit anderen auch nur
vorstellen zu können geschweige denn das
system in frage zu stellen
ich bin in einsamkeit aufgewachsen so
lange ich denken kann
aber jetzt bin ich das nie überdrüssig
ich will die welt kennenlernen von der
man mir so viel erzählt hat die männer
die man mir anpreist
wie man mir schlecht
ich will alles kennenlernen
alles fing alles besitzen ein trotzen
du wirst überrascht euch das aber hört
mich an
man kann einen franken in einen käfig
sperren und in die erinnerung und dem
instinkt der freiheit vergessen lassen
ein junger mensch aber ist ein vogel
damit einen besseren gedächtnis
begabteste wenn ich kämpft stirbt auf
raten
lieber gott danke dass ich als frau
geboren wurde
danke dass ich mir die nägel lackieren
die haare frisieren rotkäppchen film
wall and learn arielle die meerjungfrau
mitsingen und gleichzeitig studieren
karriere machen vorstände leiten und
kriege film darf danke dass dürfen noch
nicht einmal richtige ausdruck dafür ist
sondern dass diese dinge von mir
erwartet werden und die welt für alle in
ordnung ist wenn ich vorstellen oder
kriege führen solange die nägel gelangt
sind
wie soll körper sein also stelle ich ihn
aus danke dass ich kinder kriegen kann
und danke dass ich mich genauso gut
dagegen in scheinen und sie den rest
meiner tage wort gemeinsamen
bushaltestellen trinken kann bis keiner
mehr und ich wollen
danke dass du in ein anderes geschlecht
an die seite gestellt hatten von dem ich
mit einem lächeln oder meinetwegen das
sind durch rechtsverkehr bekommen kann
was ich will
danke für das schlechte gewissen der
anderen für die letzten 10.000 jahre
unterdrückung und danke für die mit der
geste der entschuldigung demütig auf
mein konto überwiesenen fördermittel
unter der kampagne der weiblichen blick
lieber gott danke dass ich eine woche
sein kann
zu dieser zeit an diesem ort als frau
geboren zu sein ist das beste was eine
kreatur und hat einer sonne passieren
kann
dieses grausame gehalten ich habe
endlich gewagt ist mit zu offenbaren
nachdem sein
wir glauben dass ich auf diese reihe
einfach lösen und zu sagen
sex gehört dieser klasse an dort sind
verweisen wir dich was ist los und
frauen unterdrücken großstadt notwendig
ich darf noch hoffen dass sich die
enttäuschung und unzufriedenheit der
menschen nicht das problem endlich
sondern ganz klassisch ging jeweils die
in der gesellschaftlichen hierarchie
freitag unten stehen er wollte mich vor
ein tribunal stellen vor einer
ansammlung von männern
aller augen ein sams verschlagen
zerrissen und einblicken diesen
weiblichen brüsten tönen und wozu das
alles
um euer recht auf macht und reichtum zu
demonstrieren aber diese letzte
demütigung werde ich nicht zulassen
lieber will ich diese brustfleisch und
diesen busen verstümmeln so dass er für
die die ihn sehen sollen ein anblick des
abschieds werden und niemand beim
anblick meiner will flächen frei eigenen
seele neuenahr kann glauben durch die
verantwortung
wie der umsetzungsprozess
weiterentwickelt werden muss liegt bei
jeder und jedem einzelnen und jeder und
jede muss diese verantwortung aufrollen
ihr seid in eure eigene falle getappt
ich kenne jetzt den wunden punkt ihres
hasses
ich will euch straßen getrieben
ihr seid meine leiden teil
foto nicola
die furcht zu schaffen
das ist die strafe und einen dünnen
[Musik]